[Music]
hello how are you greetings to him and
jaramillo with their brief informative for
today Tuesday September 14 the
problems continue inside the
ali stadium this time it was not only the
parking lot but also the
fans had difficulty
accessing the application to  checking
your vaccination status will not
work for everyone there were some
delays and long lines because of this
incident
and we continue with the raiders because yesterday they
got a win within the
leading state in front of their fans playing
against the baltimore ravens the
game was even and missing  A few
seconds tied, which forced them to
go into extra time. The laughers
ended victorious with a score
of 33 to 27
[Applause]
live spears poster this weekend,
those who attend must present
proof of vaccination, a
negative test that does not pass 72  hours
of completion if you attend several days
then you can take the
screening test today  however they
will not accept the results of tests
carried out at home if you received the
vaccine you can enter the information in
which it was the same as that used
by the raiders fans and now we turn
to the weather forecast we will have
temperatures reaching 102 degrees
for today we will continue with triple digits
for tomorrow, however, the temperatures will drop
as of Thursday, a beautiful
day, study jaramillo greets us and this
was his brief inclusion newsletter in
Spanish
[Music]